ليلى ليلى الشطوره ليلى
[موسيقى]
انا انا ليلى الحلوه الشطوره شطوره نادتني
ماما وهي مسروره انا انا ليلى الحلوه
الشطوره
نادتني ماما وهي مسروره خدي مني كاكا يا
بنيه للجده اعطيها هديه وامشي في حذر يا
بنتي لا تسمعي ابدا اغربا قابلني الذئب في
طريقي وسالني ينتظر جوابا
[موسيقى]
يا ليل الى اين الوجه يا حلوه يا احلى
صغاري يا ليلى الى اين الوجه يا حلوه يا
احلى صغاري قلت الى بيت الجده اعطيته
عنوانا داري ذهب سريعا وسبقني قد اخفى
الجده عني لبس ثيابها كي يتنكر ثم انتظر
ليخدعني
[موسيقى]
قلت لها جده اهلا يا حبي الاحلى والاجمل
لمشاكلك اصبح متغير لا يبدو لي مثل الاول
لما هكذا اذناك طويله اسمع صوتك يا جميله
عيناك تبدو جاحده اراك يا ابنتي واضحه
اسنانك اكبر تتلالا يا ليلى حاله
مرعوبه
بالصوت العالي سمع الصياد
واتى في الحال ضرب الباكر عن راسه بعدها
طارده بفسه شكرته ليلى عن فعله وتعلمت
الان الدرس لن اتحدث للغرباء ووصايا ماما
لن انسى لن اتحدث للغرباء ووصايا ماما لن
انساه
ليلى ليلى الشطوره ليلى